I just want to say thank you for joining me in the Retargeting and Crowds course.
So this is just a recap really quickly.
We first went over how to reuse animations between different characters of similar skeletal
structure and there were two main methods that we went over.
The first was animation retargeting and then the second was skeleton retargeting.
After that we went over blend spaces.
So that was if you need to blend between animations in real time during gameplay.
And then after that we used our retargeted characters and set up a crowd simulation.
And then we used the take recorder system to record the results.
So hopefully by now I hope you see the power of Unreal's retargeting features and I wish
you all the best and I'll see you next time.